lo que fue la mayor obra de ingeniería
hidráulica en España que inició
operaciones en 1979 y fue motivo de
celebración por la solidaridad entre
regiones que implicaba se ha convertido
en una de las razones de mayor tensión
nacional desde hace décadas el trasvase
Tajo segura es un sistema de
canalización de unos 260 kilómetros que
lleva agua desde el centro de España en
Castilla la Mancha hasta el sureste del
país en las provincias de alicante
murcia y Almería un área conocida como
La huerta de Europa por su actividad
agrícola que representa el 65% de las
hortalizas exportadas por España desde
2015 la cantidad de agua trasvasada ha
ido en aumento mientras que las
condiciones climáticas han ido haciendo
del agua un recurso cada vez más escaso
en toda la Península ibérica de hecho
los embalses en la cabecera de este
trasvase Tajo segura están en sus
niveles más bajos desde 1995 para estas
fechas un panorama que comparten todos
los embalses del país que están al 38,5%
de su capacidad la difícil tarea que
tienen ahora gobernantes técnicos y
ecologistas es encontrar una solución
válida a largo plazo que tenga en cuenta
las necesidades hidrológicas del sureste
agrícola español sin olvidarse de que en
este país la sequía no es algo pasajero
y que por el cambio climático empeorará
en los próximos años